- Well, being molested
by my father that my mother married to.
I'm the only one with a different father.
It just hurting me to this day
that I say, "You didn't do nothing."
She'll tell me, "You should
have said something."
How somebody don't, how a
child gone say something
with something like that
being done by a father,
somebody that your mother is married to,
how do they say something like that?
And then this the part that killed me,
this the part that killed me,
(crying)
This always hurt me!
You hear me?
She knew it was happening.
She didn't do nothing.
That's the part that will always get me,
a mother supposed to protect her child.
You hear me?
To this day, she will not own up to it.
But when that man got on his dying bed
and man said, he said,
"You be protected me all these years?"
So you hear me?
He gave me like the Lord,
and he asked me to forgive him.
And I did.
I did because if we
don't forgive somebody,
the Lord won't forgive you.
I had been through a lot
as a child with my mother.
It's all been because of her.
You hear me?
This woman remarried again.
You hear me at the age of
52, I was 52 years old.
And this man, my mother been with this man
for about 30 some years,
maybe even longer.
Here come Deja Vu, again, you hear me?
Here come Deja Vu.
You got a husband.
Yeah, He on sherm, which is PCP,
he on marijuana, he on crack cocaine.
And he doing crystal,
and he'd hit the dope.
Then he'd come around
the back of the house
and peep through my bedroom.
Now this what really made my mother
have that jealous spirit in her.
She always would fix it where she and him
would get into an argument.
And she know I'm a come to her rescue.
And then by me stepping in
trying to rescue her because
of how he talking to her.
'Cause she was a bread too.
The man would turn around
and put me out the house.
It was all like a booby
trapped by her from the get go.
She knew her husband, her husband
her second husband came on to me.
She knew it.
And when he couldn't have
me, he would put me out,
put me out of the house.
Even in the cold, she knew
I ain't had nowhere to go.
It was always what, she
cared about him and only him.
And so I used to always have the lord,
ask the Lord he go whoop you.
I said the Lord gonna whoop you
you ain't gonna even
know you being whooped.
You hear me?
'Cause of all the things
she allowed to happen to me
from a child all the way down.
Here I am in my 50s, I come
over here and I ask my mom.
Cause I ain't have nowhere to go.
Could I get a couple hours of sleep?
'Cause I was tired,
I ain't had nowhere else to go man,
I had nowhere else to go, and it was cold!
You hear me it was cold!
I ain't never gonna forget
none of this stuff I've
been going through.
She told me I could.
They got two couches in the living room.
My mom was sleeping on one couch
and I got me some rest on the other couch,
both couches face one another.
When I woke up, my mother's husband
was laying on the floor butt naked.
She on the other couch
and I'm on that one.
I'm sleeping like this on my arm.
When I woke up this man had my hand
playing with the tip of his dick.
Whilst she lay up on the couch
and play like she sleep.
She never sleep because
he always on drugs.
Till she had to stay woke just
so she could keep an eye on him.
So I say he go Deja Vu again.
I had came back again, I
asked could I get some rest.
She told me to go lay in her bed,
a bed that she don't sleep in because
they don't sleep in the bed together.
They got seven bedrooms.
I wake up, and your husband done came
and got butt naked in the bed with me.
I jumped up out the bed, ran in there,
curled up on the floor like I was a dog,
'cause we had a dog named Precious.
I just curled up on the floor,
Near the calendar where my arm laying on.
(crying)
I'm sorry, 'cause I'm just thinking about
how she always play like she
don't know nothing happen.
She already didn't teach
me about no menstruation.
About boys, cooking, no, none of that.
She already didn't teach me none of it.
I don't know what it was about me
that my mom had allowed a lot
of things to happen to me,
starting from being a child.
So, to this day, coming here to California
played a big part in my life.
But my mama, me getting away from her,
I still lived in the house with my mother.
But she keep letting things happen.
I could never take a bath in
our house unless she was there,
it killed me when he said,
"Why I can't have both of y'all?"
You hear me?
No, I didn't go back and tell
my mom none of this stuff.
A lot of it she knew it
when she played asleep,
like she did when daddy number one
would come in my room, and
you laid there in your bed
and play sleep like you
didn't know he was in room.
Now here we is, me, you
and husband number two
in the front living room.
You on the couch playing possum.
She sleep light, you know the
older you get you less asleep.
My mom is 77, I'm 57.
She had me when she was
20 years old, you hear me?
The biggest reason why I came here,
I had needed to really find the Lord,
and kept trying to grab
onto the Lord at home.
and she'll say, "You ain't got God in you.
"You don't even know God."
She'll say things, and she'll make up lies
and have my sister and them
thinking I'm trying to hurt her.
Just a jealous spirit.
By to this day. my momma
still with that man.
She still love that man.
He always say why I
can't have both of y'all?
Why can't have I both of y'all?
This man was something else.
And could just go on with his life.
I couldn't believe my mother.
I call her. I call my mother right now,
a monster because she is one.
What mother going to let
their child get molested, man?
I haven't talked about this
the day you interviewed me.
Oh Lord have mercy, Jesus!
What mother would let
her child get molested?
He gave me a last name.
He raised me.
I still stuck with him,
and called him dad.
After being molested by this man,
all the way till I'm grown, you hear me?
And she had a skeleton
in the closet, secrecy.
She would still deny it to this day.
Let me tell you something.
I'm the only one in my
family ever got on drugs.
I came from a good family,
a good old fashioned family.
What mother going to
let a child get molested
and don't do nothing?
A mother supposed to protect.
I hear about kids getting
molested all the time.
But not the mother knowing about it.
And she let it go on for awhile,
till one day when we
came home from school.
My mother made sure we
packed all our stuff up
to leave, to move out and leave my dad.
She didn't tell us why
we were leaving my dad,
but I knew, I guessed it.
I was letting my two
sisters know up under me
by me being the oldest child and a tomboy,
to not let nothing happen to them,
'cause then I would open my mouth.
I would say something.
This lady kept this, I told
her when he got ready to die,
I couldn't wait, I couldn't wait.
I said, "If daddy die, I'm coming out
"the closet with your skeletons, "
because that's a mother who
taught verbal abuse to me.
Verbal abuse to me.
I wasn't no bad child, I was a good child.
And for me not to go to counseling,
for a mother not to admit she know it,
that just turned me upside down.
That turned me upside down.
You hear me?
I got one boy.
I didn't want no more kids in life!
I asked him not to send me a girl,
because of what happened to me?
Oh, I treat my son the way a mother
is supposed to treat they child.
You hear me?
Because he had a grandfather,
then my mom end up, she end
up marrying another guy.
Oh my God!
(crying)
Oh Lord have mercy, Jesus!
It's my mother, we
battle right to the day.
I'm 57 years old, me and
her battle to this day.
I knew she, she did.
She kept putting me in different rehabs,
a family who don't do no
drugs, no smoking, no drinking.
And then this one child, this one child
comes up on all this
different type of shit.
This one child.
The most educated one in
the family, you hear me?
The most educated one, the seamstress,
(indistinct)
I'm the last of our generation
that's a seamstress.
Every day, every day I went to school
I ain't never wanna see
nobody with nothing I had on.
I go to the fabric store,
pick out the type of fabric.
My pattern, my mother made
everything I wore in my life,
until I got off into something.
She didn't teach me about no menstruation,
she didn't teach me about no boys.
The one that molested me
taught me how to cook an egg,
over easy sunny side up with a yoke.
He the one taught me how to cook.
I didn't understand that you
knew he was doing this to me,
and she didn't want to teach me nothing
that I'm supposed to know as growing up.
So I had some first cousins that were,
and look they daddy was molested them!
Oh boy!
It's like an incest family.
But that one was bad.
I can't believe me and my mom...
Are still feuding because she don't wanna
ask me to forgive her.
But she don't know I'm already,
I've already forgave her.
This lady here, she's thinking
what it took to achieve.
She so ungodly.
I remember, she would get mad at me.
(crying)
And I felt like she didn't
want me in her life no more!
And I hadn't done nothing to my mother.
It's just that she had this kind of
spirit on her towards me.
And so I said,
(crying)
I think my momma would be
happy if I take my life.
So, I tried to do that.
(crying)
I took all her medications.
She had three types she was on,
and I sat down in her
chair, inside her house.
I waited for her to come home for work.
And I was hoping she would
find me dead in her recliner.
I guess the Lord said it wasn't time
for me to go yet because my
mom came home and woke me up.
She was so mad at me, she was mad
'cause I had took her medication.
Not because of what I
tried to do to myself.
I had my hand gun license.
I had a Billy Bob and Bessie, 32 and 38.
But I had really, I sold drugs,
and end up getting rid of both
of my guns to dope dealers.
Then when I did decide to take my life,
so my guns weren't in
my possession no more.
She said, "Instead of taking my medication
"you should have shot yourself in the head
"with one of your pistols."
Oh boy.
You have to bring me
coming here to California,
getting away from her.
That's why I left Houston was for me
to grab on to the Lord here.
Long as I kept stay away from her,
she wouldn't distract me from trying
to build my relationship with the Lord.
You hear me?
It made her mad that I came here.
She tried to scare me not to come,
because I don't know nobody here.
All I knew is I had needed to build
a relationship with the Lord
because I'm slipping again.
I'm slipping into a state of mind
of giving up on life again.
And I wasn't even on no
drugs before I left here.
Before I left Houston, you hear me?
That woman know how to say some things
to me that makes me
want to give up on life.
When the Bible said that the tongue
is full of deadly poison that
cook like a double edge blade.
I'm a witness, I'm a witness.
And this woman knows that
things she say to me,
I'm a do what makes her happy.
I knew I ain't have no family hear,
but I knew I had needed
to grab on to the Lord
because that lady is my downfall.
And I said, I told him,
I said, I see a wolf!
(crying)
I said I see a wolf in sheep's clothing!
I said, you, my mother!
(crying)
I said, "And I still got to love you."
And she gonna tell me,
"You ain't got to love."
I said, "My God, my
God, I got to love you."
Do you know how hard it is
to live in the same house
with one that's ungodly and
one that's trying to be godly?
'Cause if I don't try to be godly,
Satan gonna get me all the way!
The one sin he won't forgive,
that the Lord won't forgive me for,
(indistinct)
I can kill myself today.
It ain't gonna make me no difference.
I heard that coming here
to California was bad.
It's so hard here for me,
because men want you to use your body
for everything you need.
They ain't got no morals, no principles.
I did that back in the 80s.
I ain't had no sex.
I been here over a year.
I ain't sucked no dicks, I
don't even get with women.
That's where the Lord made
me strong at, you hear me?
That's where he made me strong at,
with my body this time and my mind.
Sooner or later, coming here I'm a cross
all the way over to the Lord.
Coming here make you talk to the Lord.
I'm so scared here, it
makes me talk to the Lord.
I'm doing a whole lot better
than the last interview.
I done gained some weight.
I'm more off into my Lord.
I share the Bible with people,
I'm just taking baby steps.
But before I go back to Houston,
I gotta have the Lord all the way in me.
I got to, because that's a demon in her,
and we have real demons,
evil spirits, principalities
swirling all around us and
we just can't see them.
You hear me?
To want to take my life was evil.
For her to say, I should
have shot myself in the head,
was mean, I call it a monster.
She was doing things to me in my sleep.
Cutting my hair, putting plugs in it.
Oh man, jewelry coming up...
I really believe my box of oatmeal,
the pot of dry oatmeal, Quaker Oats?
I used to tell my sister, I said
"I think somebody done put
something in my oatmeal."
She said "Alicia, that's crazy."
Don't never think family don't get so evil
where they'll do something
like that, and it hurts.
And they might not want to believe it,
because it's your own mother!
But anytime I ain't doing no drugs,
it's something is helping me sleep.
And only way you could give it to me
is because you know I love oatmeal,
day and night, day and
night, powdered oatmeal.
I don't put it past them.
I even talked to the police
about me getting some counseling,
'cause I didn't need nobody
thinking I was crazy,
because I was going crazy for real.
For thinking that they were
doing these things to me,
and guess what they was.
They was, it wasn't me!
They was doing these things to me.
And then when she got with the man
that she married the new one,
and he 10 years younger than her.
He on syrup, crack,
marijuana, Kush, alcohol.
And then this one man you been
with you for 25, 30 years!
Y'all done took the
bathroom knob off the door.
I can take no bath at that
house unless my mama is there.
I do everything not to hurt
her and go against the grain,
because I know how much
she loves this man.
But I would never go against the grain
and mess with my stepfather.
Somebody that my mother love.
The stepfather stayed
after me for the longest,
until I had come here.
And this woman will sleep on
the couch in the living room.
The stepfather had
talked to my mom so bad,
till I stepped in, I said nigga,
that man was fighting me
like a man, you hear me?
He kept calling my mama
a fat gray-haired bitch.
I told him you ain't going to sit there
and let somebody call your
mama a fat gray-haired bitch?
I had needed him to understand that
because I had to open my mouth,
doing some bad language to her.
My mother is the bread.
He gets a check, $1,231, but
he don't do shit with it.
Dope man get the whole goddamn check.
She got him like that!
She got him like that because instead of
making him pay bills and responsibility,
fixing things around
the house, she didn't.
She let him go like he wanted.
And he did.
He did try to go like he wants.
She just didn't know how
far he was trying to go.
But I would tell my sisters
everything (indistinct)
I said, "She done did Deja vu again!"
I said, "Momma can I come
in and sleep on the couch
"for a couple hours, I'm tired?"
'Cause he had put me out the
house because of my mouth.
But his mouth was just as worse.
I felt like he ain't had no business
disrespecting momma and
she paid all the bills
and property taxes, and
then all of a sudden
you wanna be disrespectful,
and then tell me
that you want both of us,
but I didn't tell my mom that part.
No, I didn't tell my mom that.
Right to this day, my mom
still with that same man.
Ain't no way in the world I can go back
without my full armor of God on me.
I know I need the armor,
I know I need him all the way in me!
I feel good right now,
'cause I know the Lord's
got his arms around me!
You understand me!
I been through so much, that
it makes you talk to the Lord!
All these people who can go
get counseling, psychiatrist.
I couldn't go do that!
I ain't have that!
I talk to the Lord.
(crying)
He the only one man be
listening, you hear me?
Them some spirits over there, her and him.
I'm going to get better.
It's better.
I'm not doing some of the,
a lot of things at the
other women are doing.
It's hard for me to come up
with a little money to
get something to eat,
because I don't go that extra day.
I just started getting
food stamps this month.
This month.
(indistinct)
Yes I am.
And you know something else,
I don't use crack like I used to.
I seen lesser not than before.
I'm going be all right, I'm glad I'm here
because it makes me.
I can't go home because
they'll get me there
them things get me there.
(coughs)
Then as long as I stay here,
I be so scared being here.
I just run my (indistinct)
I don't do drugs like I used to know more,
especially the crack.
I tried to smoke a little marijuana,
it's not my drug of choice,
but it's a downer that I'm
using to suppress an upper.
I don't know no other way.
I don't want to get you hooked
on no other drug, pills and shooting
I ain't never done none of that.
Don't do no good to talk
to any of my family,
'cause they don't even have street sense,
drug, no none of that.
I can't really depend
on nobody but the Lord.
And if it's meant for him to put
the people in my life to help me.
And when they bless me with things
I better use it wisely
because it's too many days
I don't do without
eating without a person,
"Well, what are you gonna do for me?"
I can't believe this man.
But then that's my fault.
If I don't hurry up pull myself together,
get my mouth fix get me a job
than okay that's what happens
actually on the streets
here in California or blade.
And it's so hard, it's so
hard I be so hungry sometimes,
to I don't even want to be going
to sleep hungry, you hear me?
Staying on the street,
these guys go to sleep
with your clothes on,
and goddamn it you'll
wake up with 'em all off.
Can't go to sleep in these people tents.
You ever get tired, come here.
It ain't nobody you can trust.
Not family, not step dads,
not the people on the streets.
Child, I'm learning from my mistakes.
Everything I go through
that the Lord allow me to go through,
I learned from and I
try not to repeat again.
Going to sleep somewhere and wake up
and ain't got no goddamn clothes on,
just just did me, that
just took my cake there!
You hear me?
I never saw people like that in Houston
to wake up and don't
have nothing on, nothing.
They had to put something
in something I drunk,
offered me something to drink.
And it wasn't beer.
It had to be Kool-Aid
or soda or something.
But these people here,
I say, they say it's
the city of lost angels.
I believe it's a lot of spirits here.
It's a lot of spirits here.
I feel them, even in that
building that I'm living in.
It's a lot of spirits here,
it's a lot of spirits here.
I've been here now for a year
out and I have not let a man get to me.
You hear me?
I have not allowed one to come in my life.
Not just being my friend.
Not nothing!
You hear me?
No sex.
I been here a year and
I ain't done no sex.
Can you believe that?
Huh?
My mind so messed up from the mess
happening with me with my daddy
and then my stuff with my step daddy.
That's why I ain't had
nothing but one child.
I thank the Lord he gave me a boy,
'cause I probably would've
been over protective
if he had blessed me with a girl.
I'm on drugs, you hear me,
and not as bad as I used to be.
And these men can't pay me.
They can't give me no drugs, no crack
to have my body, or for
me to suck they dick.
You hear me?
All this stuff made me stronger.
The stuff I'm going through.
I don't care if I be hungry,
If I turn to certain people and I'm saying
can I have some money
to get something to eat,
you better believe it I'm hungry,
because I won't go that other extra mile
to do the things that these men
be wanting you to do
to degrade yourself, to degrade yourself
just so you could get something to eat.
I get on a job, I work
harder than these men.
I ain't scared to do no work.
I got callouses on my hand.
I ain't never had a man
send me to the beauty shop.
I don't know what it's like to have
my toes and my nails did.
No none of that.
I be lonesome here, I'm lonesome here.
These ladies are not friendly.
It's an epidemic going around
in this hood, it's Skid Row.
You hear me, they have
too much unprotected sex.
They need some health
trucks to come out here
in this little area here.
If I was a man I wouldn't let a woman
suck my dick without a condom.
You hear me?
These women don't go to the doctor.
These women, they don't try,
I don't tote condoms, 'cause
I ain't finna do nothing.
I ain't going to do nothing.
I don't care if I was
jonesin for his joint,
if I was hungry.
I done had men put me out
of the cold out in tents
'cause I wouldn't get them none.
Don't tell me I can come in
out of the cold and warm up
and get some rest ain't
nobody gonna bother you
I heard that before when I woke up
with no goddamn clothes on, you hear me?
I can't tell if somebody
done had sex with me on not.
And right now, let me tell you the Lord...
The Lord has got you working in my life.
Can't nobody made me believe that the Lord
don't have you in my life,
the Lord got you in my life.
You better believe that.
You better believe that, so help me, God.
I ask that the Lord help
you to feel it in your heart
that's the truth, I mean it.
Crack don't do nothing but
tear your body down
and your immune system.
These are facts that I'm
telling you about this drug.
I gave it a name, I call
it the devil love potion.
You don't benefit from it.
I thank the Lord that I'm
slacked up on the drug.
I thank the Lord for
and every time he fix it
where I end up meeting with you,
'cause if I want another job
this whole time I fixin'
have this kind of money
when you give it to me, in an honest way.
And I had to think that
the Lord is behind it.
And so I be scared to misuse my money.
I be scared, I be scared!
I know where it come from.
I know it done came from
the Lord through you.
Bet not spend that money, spend a penny
of that hundred dollars on some drugs.
You hear me, I be too
scared, I be too scared.
Lord knows I do and I
don't, 'cause if I do
Lord might stop me from
making my hundred dollars,
you hear me?
You know how hard it is
when you give me that money
and to steady do right with
it all the way to the penny?
You know how hard that is for me?
And I'm a drug addict.
How hard that is when
you give me that money
and I walk out that door to not spend
my money on no drugs?
It's very hard for me,
it's very hard for me,
and I don't neither.
I don't spend not a penny on it.
'Cause the Lord will take that money.
Just like he blessed me to get it.
He'll stop me from getting it.
He'll stop me.
And any time you would say you,
I did right with it, I
did right with my money.
People be trying to
convince me to (indistinct)
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
I'm getting stronger,
I'm getting stronger.
You help us to vent,
'cause we be done held
so much stuff in and we don't
talk to nobody about it.
You hear me?
Huh, we don't talk to know about it!
But then when you come in
and have to tell your story,
it's just like going through something
that's therapeutic for you, you hear me?
It's therapeutic for me to get the things
that's done happened
to me to talk about it
and not hold it in.
It helps me.
So, it's so many ways you be helping us,
with the financial side to talk about it
and get it off our chest.
So hard talking about something
that's done happened that's painful to us.
You be helping us in so many ways,
they just don't be knowing.
That's why it's good to bless the Lord,
for people he be putting in your life.
And if you ain't trying
to get close to the Lord
they won't even see that you're a blessing
when you really is,
you're a blessing for me.
You're gonna always be a part
of my heart, you hear me?
You will always be a part of my heart.
I ain't gonna never let you go.
I ain't never let you go!
You hear me, because that
was so important to me
for you to hear me about
what's done happened to me,
that's important to me.
That's so important to me.
(crying)
It's important to me and don't nobody else
be wanting to listen to it.
(crying)
I'm not going to never let you go.
I'm not gonna never let you go!
You not gone ever be
able to get rid of me!
And I mean it!
(indistinct)